well our next guest is at the heart of
two very big stories this week he's a
leading brexit supporter and the
architect of the flagship welfare reform
Universal Credit so welcome to you and
it feels like we should start off with
brexit big story and of course as always
and we understand openly that Theresa
Mays latest can backstop offer to the EU
would effectively keep the UK in a
customs union I mean is that something
you could support well not really and
it's very difficult to quite know what
is going on at the moment so if I just
take a pace back people voted to leave
they didn't vote to half leave they
didn't vote to half join they voted to
leave it was a particularly a decision
you know take back control of our laws
our borders and our money and I think
therefore you have to see everything
through that little prism what how does
it measure up I think what's very clear
is we had agreed and implementation
period providing we had a deal and that
also hinged 39 billion pounds to the EU
if we got that deal if we end up staying
in the customs union for that
implementation period we would de facto
be in the customs union anyway but the
key question is when does it end and it
has to end in a very specific way
because being in the customs union is
not what the people voted for wouldn't
be all to do any trade deals wouldn't be
able to look at anything with the USA or
with Japan has been talking about
bringing us into the trans-pacific
partnership all that would not happen so
if there's no clear end date for this
backstop planned customs union plan you
would vote against a deal that included
it yeah I think it's not just end date
by the way it's a little bit more than
that it's not just having an end date
it's knowing that the UK government will
be able to leave if it was to agree to
stay in the customs you know which I by
the way think should only be over the
period of the implementation phase I do
not see any reason why longer then it
should be not then dated but controlled
by the UK the second bit is we're in
this mess because the government keeps
refusing to take on head on the issue of
the backstop it was a mistake in
December last year I told the Prime
Minister walk away from the table do not
sign this it
box you in and the problem is that the
EU and Ireland insist that you have to
have a hard board if there is no deal
it's complete rubbish even Barney in
admits it doesn't happen I mean we wrote
a paper the other day our group of us to
say basically that it's wholly feasible
to have an open border it Dover as well
as in Northern Ireland without border
checks at all under existing
technologies and procedures that's been
accepted by the way by everybody so it's
pretty clear that you're not happy with
the kind of way that to reason may is
perhaps moving and towards the EU do you
support David Davis's call this morning
for a kind of cabinet mutiny if you like
to try and kill it off I share one thing
in common with David Davis which is
we've both resigned from a cabinet when
we weren't in agreement with it and
therefore I'm always of the view that
when you get to the point where you no
longer agree on a fundamental issue then
it's probably time that you found
yourself on the back benches but it's up
to people to do that themselves so do
you think we could see some resignations
over Mike I am never a very good
speculated but I do say to anyone who's
in cabinet who has concerns about this
you have to make them very clear to the
Prime Minister and we mustn't have a
little cabal outside the cabinet running
this it has to be a cabinet decision and
more importantly I think the real
question here is we have a very strong
set of cards to play 39 billion and
security are all on the table at the
moment and the EU we know BMW and others
are now beginning to moan so a very good
speech made by an MEP call Henkel in the
European Parliament the other day and I
watched it and he really went for Yunker
and said you messed up before the
referendum and you're about to mess up
now and he used a very interesting
figure he said the departure of Britain
isn't just you know it isn't bad for
Britain it's a disaster for you he said
it's the equivalent of 9 small or medium
countries leaving the EU at once we will
all over here suffer you have to have a
proper deal with them and so I'm very
simple message I say to the Romans and
others look it's great if you're going
to be a bloody difficult woman over
something absolutely real strength when
you're on the right course but when
you're not on the right course sometimes
you need to compare to take a pace back
and say is there a better way and I
think there is a better way to do this
which is to put the ball back in the
--use court and say
we have never accepted this back stock
this is a ludicrous political
intervention you now must agree with us
there will never be a hard border with
or without a deal and then full Canada
plus plus trade deal is on the table you
talk about trees made there being a
bloody difficult woman I wonder if
you're prepared bloody difficult back
bencher there's been talk hasn't there
about backbenchers being prepared to
vote down the budget for example to
effectively wage a campaign of
insurrection to try and forth theresa
made to change direction i'm not in
favor of a kind of insurrection we have
a government and we have a party to stay
together we have to get through this
together and come out the other side
together otherwise for us the big threat
much bigger than bricks is jeremy corbyn
with a terrible plan to basically tax
the hell out of the country so would you
back the reason they don't there was a
no-confidence vote i don't want to see a
leadership change i want to see a
leadership change her mind and go in a
different direction and to listen to
people who say look nobody voted to stay
in the customs union we want to get
through this and out the other end
people out there have decided let's get
on with it let's deliver it let's get
out and now I'm keeps talking about
universal credit so it's been in the
news an awful lot recently a lot of
criticism now when you first announced
the policy eight years ago we can just
have a look at what you said and which
is hopefully coming up and it's a proud
duty to provide financial security to
the most environmental not change this
is our contract with the most vulnerable
indeed currently do you think the
Conservatives have broken that contract
I don't I don't yet when I set universal
credit it was because I studied for some
years the mess that the tax credit
system had got into Housing Benefit all
these different places people went to
got confused quite often you know single
women were going to work lose their jobs
of 15 hours after a while they'd come
out take nearly two months to get their
Housing Benefit back and we know that
with tax credits many of us had people
coming into our surgeries saying after a
year of bad estimates they ended up with
massive debts on their hands in fact as
tax credit recipients go over to you see
they've been Kerry
about six billion pounds worth of tax
credit debts with them as well as the
housing benefit debts so any wonderful
idea is that what this replaces was not
damaging our mad it the very bad system
we had before so the purpose of
universal credit was to make things
simpler to understand so that people
knew they made one claim and more
importantly she's forgotten they have a
human person there another person who is
their advisor they can go and see and
talk to see there's not aimed sound very
noble those are some of the analysis is
worrying the Work and Pensions secretary
admitting some people will be worse off
the resolution foundation saying three
million people families will lose more
than 200 let me bring that into context
consent so the structure of what's
ruling out is rolling out well it's
nearly out to all the job centers and
the advisers having a much better
relationship and there are tens of
thousands of people who find this a
better system however you're talking
about the money so when I launched this
we specifically set down an amount of
money that would allow this to roll out
correctly and have the levels of
payments at the right level in the 2015
spending review a very significant
amount of money was taken out in
Universal Credit I had big issues over
that there was another attempt to take
more money out and around Christmas 2015
and for me that was the final straw I
then resigned it was there a number of
other changes and cuts to which I didn't
agree with including the disability one
my view is and has been for some time
the government has a really really
transformative policy on its hands you
do not understand
because if you do that then what you do
is lose the great benefit of it and then
end up starving people I know
potentially breaking that contract with
them if you if just going back to you
know your promise to look after most
vulnerable I mean one of the things that
people are saying now is that some of
the people who could be about to lose
out those who are the most vulnerable
loan parents for example yeah I mean
your father you know how difficult it
bring up a child these are people in
work I couldn't agree with you more
people trying to do the right thing
which is why for the last two and a half
years I've proposed constantly that we
put the money that was taken out it was
nearly five billion was taken out back
in so five billion pounds well the
government the government has actually
been quite good they put about two
back in what's left is about between 2
and 3 billion I would think addressing
the budget to you well I think it's
wholly feasible you don't have to add
any new spending they have a plan at the
moment to raise the tax thresholds which
is a manifesto commitment but problems
we've raised them so high now that most
of the poorest don't get affected by
another rise in tax thresholds about 20%
would get any benefit from this because
so many are out of tax
whereas with universal credit if you put
the money that was there into the
lounge's which is like a tax threshold
for very poor people the natural fact
what you do is nearly 80% of your money
goes straight to the poorest for deciles
now I think it's a no-brainer if you
take that money you will deliver on what
I said and at the same time you will
really include and prove the lifestyles
of people in the poorest circumstances
that's what universal credit was
designed to do it's why I brought it in
it is now ready to do that we just need
to grab this bull by the horns and say
this money should go right to the
poorest I'm just having a no you're not
on Twitter possibly very sensible but
just in the break just having a look at
some of them your lation that I can then
see to the interview for example
somebody talking about and ending of
Smith whose shoulders no responsibility
for the complete screw-up of universal
credit and is it helpful some of because
because you you clearly people who have
a very vested interests does is it
hurtful that for some people you were
the face
of all the problems with universal
credit and how some people would view is
the kind of nasty party if you like yeah
but it's not I mean the point is that
you can believe that if you want that's
you know sometimes people get ridiculous
politicized I mean momentum troll
everybody at the moment so there's just
no way out of that my point however
though is this benefit was deliberately
set having to be rolled out in as a test
and learn process you know when tax
credits were rolled out they were rolled
out in one go nearly three quarters of a
million people didn't get their money at
all and have never received their money
so the implementation so the
implementation was deliberately careful
and slow we looked at this we did it
like this so when you meet an issuer
problem you check whether it's an
operational problem or a technical
problem then you make the adjustments
accordingly
that's exactly what's been going on last
Christmas they made some
once I was recommending those as well
changes to the way in which people
coming off housing benefit coming on
could continue to keep their housing
benefit so they invested another billion
and that was exactly the point that I'm
making so Universal Credit is a better
benefit what's very rarely happens is
people don't hear from the tens of
thousands of people who actually find
this a much better benefit they're
allowed to take very low hours work if
necessary their while caring
responsibilities so getting it rights
important I'm not shirking any
responsibilities I resigned back in 2016
because I did not agree with the
government's position over taking the
money out of this and a couple of other
areas do you take any responsibility for
what some would see as the design flaws
in universal credit things like for
example people having to wait five weeks
for a payment I mean if you're on an
bread line then that no surprise is that
that people are falling behind on rent
payments at the having to rely on food
banks wait for that amount of time just
be very careful though benefits have
always been paid in arrears there's some
kind of mystery that somehow previous
benefits were paid in advance they've
never been paid in advance they're paid
in arrears and they're paid they were
then paid at two weeks in arrears the
plan for universal credit was a month in
arrears for a very good reason the vast
majority of jobs actually pay a month in
arrears if you aren't capable of coping
with that then you're going to go into a
job and crash out quite quickly so
there's another element that runs
alongside universal credit which hasn't
been completely rolled out it's called
universal support so the idea with
universal credit doesn't just pay a
benefit if you identify somebody who has
a problem debt problems etc they're
moved to universal support working with
the local authorities the charities and
all those other bodies in the local area
they're then put onto debt counseling or
if they have drugs problems they're
meant to be moved over into
rehabilitation the point about universal
credit it will identify that minority of
people who have real problems who will
not be able to move in to work with
those problems and then try and resolve
them that's the real design of you see
it's not completely rolled out in that
sense we need to put more effort onto
universal support which is the parallel
bit beside it which allows those
advisers to be able to say right this
individual now needs to get into some
kind of remedial help before we can get
them back into work quick thought and
what you make of Labor's position it
feels as if it's
perhaps slightly shifting John McDonnell
saying that they wanted to get rid of it
Shami Chakrabarti was slightly more
circumspect yeah it's all very well to
attack but you're quite right
labor at the moment are I think in a bit
of a mess because at first they said
well you know before Corbin came in they
were supportive and they wanted to get
changes made then suddenly it was sweep
it all the way we'll go back to another
system which you know frankly if anybody
thinks tax credits or housing benefits
were in any way fair then they really
need to have their brains examined so
now they seem as you said in that
interview to say well well if the
government puts the money in which is
what I want then we will continue to
look at the mechanisms but there's one
area where they're in a real mess over
and this is the problem there has always
been agreement on both sides of the
house
that if people don't do what they've
been asked to do while they receive
benefits then they would stand to lose
some of those benefits for a period of
time
labour has said that will never happen
that means someone never turning up to
an interview never bothering to do
anything with regards to taking the job
or anything they've been asked to do
specific to receiving that benefit
taxpayers will end up paying a huge
amount more money finally who is to
blame you've admitted that there are
issues with universal credit but not a
very vulnerable people could be worse
off who's to blame is it George Osborne
is it to resume is an estimate they know
I think the key thing is that the
structure works you need to put the
money in I think this government is
listening I think the Chancellor is
listening and I'm asking him to do that
if we do that and get the money back to
where it should be the reality is that
nobody should lose at all and if you
don't well if we don't I'm going to
continue to badger away because I think
it's the right thing to do and one thing
I've always said and Teresa Mary stood
on the steps of down in the street
and said I want to look after those who
are just managing universal credit is
the single best instrument to get to
those who are just managing it's better
than the tax system it's better than
charitable giveaways it gets the money
to that bottom for deciles in a way that
no other system does in nuggets me thank
you very much
you